su libertad es la nuestra nos apagó al
regar sus una palabra y rechazando la
vida diplomática escogiendo la guerra
del presidente putin no solamente atacó
a ucrania decidió golpear la soberanía
de ucrania decidió
atacar de manera grave a la paz y la
estabilidad en nuestra europa desde hace
décadas
ya habíamos anticipado juntos esta
crisis
y al lado de nuestros aliados y socios
europeos hicimos todo para evitarlo pero
aquí está y estamos listos
ante este acto de guerra vamos a
responder con sangre fría determinación
y sin debilidades también con unidad
vamos a tomar decisiones con el reciente
esta tarde con el consejo europeo que se
llevará a cabo esta tarde en bruselas y
la cumbre de la otan que se llevará a
cabo en las próximas horas vamos a pedir
a rusia que rinda cuentas al consejo de
seguridad es de nación su unidad y vamos
a tratar de construir la unidad
internacional en las sanciones contra
rusia estarán a la altura de la agresión
y en el plano militar y económico tanto
en el marco de la energía no tendremos
debilidad vamos a apoyar a ucrania sin
lugar y vamos a tomar todas nuestras
responsabilidades para proteger la
soberanía y la seguridad de nuestros
aliados europeos
queridos compatriotas
los eventos de esta noche son un punto
de inflexión en la historia de europa y
de nuestro país y tendrán consecuencias
durables y profundas
en nuestras vidas
tendrán consecuencias
en la geopolítica de nuestro continente
y juntos podremos responder
quiero
comunicarles mi determinación para
protegerlos y proteger a nuestros
compatriotas expuestos en ucrania
proteger a todos los franceses y tomar
todas las decisiones que se impondrán en
cuanto a las consecuencias directas e
indirectas de esta crisis
en estos momentos difíciles
vuelven a nacer los pasados los
fantasmas del pasado con manipulaciones
zelaya y no vamos a ceder nada de
nuestra unidad unidad alrededor de
nuestros principios de libertad de
soberanía y de democracia
estos principios nos hicieron y nos
mantienen juntos
el mensaje de mi parte será pronunciado
en el parlamento y volveré ante ustedes
las próximas horas para mantenerlos
informados de la evolución de la
situación y de las decisiones que tendré
que tomar
que viva la república libre y viva
francia